[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
me
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
look at me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you time
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
it seems yeah me
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
okay
ah
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
is
[Music]
place
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
please
[Music]
great
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
i knew what happened
[Music]
[Music]
a street
[Music]
is
i must wait for the sunrise
nice to meet you
me
[Music]
the trees in the sun
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
you'll understand what happens
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's
again
[Music]
i'm not really
and it's the sure i knew
[Music]
sing us a song tonight
you've got to spell
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
[Music]
besides bill i believe this
[Music]
if i could get out of this
[Music]
it's a real
[Music]
and probably will be
[Music]
i'm the waitress is
[Music]
but it's better than drinking
[Music]
[Music]
it all right
[Music]
cause he knows
[Music]
smells like a beer
[Music]
what are you doing here
[Music]
[Music]
and you've gotta feel it all right
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
1972
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
hey
i'm doing this
probably gonna start a
[Music]
so fight it's time to leave
[Music]
me
[Music]
just
give me one good reason baby come
now i on come to see
you may hate me
i just want to tell you that i had
another crazy but it ain't
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
let's
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
she was more like a beauty queen from a
[Music]
movie
people always
young girls
she's
[Music]
advice
the people always told me be careful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she says
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
to get what i
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
tonight
[Music]
me
wow
[Music]
[Music]
just a man and his will to survive too
[Music]
on fast dreams of the past you must
fight
just to keep them alive
[Music]
is
[Music]
over here
[Music]
is
what's i'm not gonna stop
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i am
outsiders
please please please
please please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
got me wrong
please please please
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i wanna be
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i paid my dues
time after time
[Music]
mistakes
i've met a few
[Music]
till the end
[Music]
cause we are the champions
[Music]
i
[Music]
and i
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
me baby
[Music]
[Music]
in the morning
he's a macho man
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
always
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
okay
not so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and their works are really clear so
faded
[Music]
faded
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
breathe
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
who gave
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of
from texas down to houston
and new york to lane
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
who gave that
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
that's a lot of people wow
thank you very much this is quite a
crowd
this is quite a crowd thank you very
much hello arizona
hello arizona
and hello to everybody right here in
nevada i love nevada too
you got nevada we have arizona
how many people are from arizona
how many people are from nevada
i bet not bad that's not bad six days
from now we are going to win
arizona we are going to win nevada
and we are going to win four more years
in our great white
house
ah look at the fake news back there
there's a lot of them
there's a lot of them you know i got a
poll this morning we're one up in
wisconsin right
we were there last night it was very
cold
it was very cold but we had a great time
a tremendous crowd
like this a tremendous crowd and then
tonight
i hear last night i heard but this
morning i get a fake poll
so we're one up in a real poll or even
or whatever but we'll end up winning it
but i get a poll abc washington post
their fx
trump 17 down in wisconsin
17. thank you thank you
and they tried it last time four years
ago too and that didn't work out too
well it's just unbelievable
how dishonest the media is i say it
because
there they are just very dishonest
people
very dishonest the vote for me is a vote
for massive middle-class tax cuts
regulation cuts fair trade strong
borders
and american energy independence
it's a vote to support our police
support our military defend our second
amendment which is
under siege stand up to china
and as your more products are proudly
stamped
with that beautiful phrase you know what
the phrase is
made in the usa
we will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth and a safe vaccine is coming
very quickly you're going to have it
momentarily that eradicates the virus
and we're rounding the turn regardless
you know that we've got the vaccine
i say regardless they'll say well maybe
you don't we have it great companies
and quickly ends the pandemic should
have never come here from china they
should have never let it out we'll never
forget
all over the world all over the world
you see what's happening in europe all
over the world
normal life will fully resume that's
what we want right normal life
normal life and next year will be the
greatest economic year
in the history of our country
a vote for sleepy joe biden and he is a
sleepy guy i'll tell you what
you know it's a powerful party
and the party is totally joined with the
fake news media the lame stream media
right there
and they're totally joined with the big
temp big tech
i don't know section 230 does anyone
know what section 230 you do
section 230 i think
[Music]
you know tremendous corruption behalf of
the
biden tremendous do you know you can't
find it anywhere in the media
other than the new york post which i'm
very proud of and they endorsed me the
other day too by the way
but you can't find it anywhere in the
media
anywhere it's not on any of the these
not on facebook
they have trending they always put me
trending they'll give you 25 things that
i've done over my life
they make it negative always negative
trending
but sleepy joe biden with all the
corruption all the theft all the money
they took out of these countries
that we end up paying for in spades
you can't find it on big tech and you
can't find it at the washington post the
new york times
because they're crooked they're
dishonest and we caught them we caught
them
just like we caught them spying on our
campaign
just like we caught him spying on our
campaign
wake autumn spine
a vote for biden is a vote for the
biggest tax hike
in the history of our country this is
the only guy i've ever seen
he's campaigning because he has no clue
he's shot just so you understand
and i'll say it because i've said hey
i've seen enough
i've seen enough is a guy gets caught
and the media doesn't want to write
about it
you know what they call it not freedom
of the press suppression of the press
we don't have freedom in the press you
know what we don't have
you understand that we don't have
freedom of the press
we have suppression of the press and
there's never been a time
when it's more obvious than right now is
that right
is that right charlie hi dan
he wants crushing regulation he by the
way he doesn't want him
he has no idea where he is they carried
him off the stage yesterday give me a
break
his people grabbed him get him off get
him off he's trying to make it to the
finish line
i mean it's honestly it's a disgrace the
whole thing is a con job
should have never been the candidate and
you know what they have a
they have a corrupt party and all of
this work being done by big tech
and being done by the media that should
be considered a major massive billion
dollar
campaign contribution because that's
what it is
they slash medicare and social security
he wants to knock out your medicare your
social security
and he wants to abolish a thing called
american energy you see that
right no fracking there'll be no
fracking no for a year he's going no
fracking he gets the nomination he goes
to pennsylvania
they tell him joe you have to change oh
okay what do you want me to say
i love frackie and say i love so he goes
from no fracking do i love fracking
a vote for sleepy joe biden is a vote
for open borders offshoring jobs
shredding your second amendment which is
totally under siege by the way
you're so lucky i'm your president
thank you what a nice group
by the way we are substantially up in a
state known as
arizona do you know about that
substantially
and i hear we're up in nevada is that
right michael we're up in nevada
we're a little concerned with all those
ballots floating around in nevada
got a lot of balance floating around in
nevada hey you know it's windy as hell
out here
you know i said is it windy should i
bring a
because i hat love my hair flopping
around one thing
at least i figured out after three years
that it is mine if it wasn't i would
have found out about it today
you know should i put on a hat
should i put it on like
nice hat
[Music]
i want to know who has worn this hat
before that's all i wanted
[Music]
yeah it's pretty it's pretty nasty am i
allowed to do it i'll do it if you want
otherwise
what a guy yes better
nice hat you know we're gonna change
your hat
so we made america great again we
created the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and then we had the plague come in from
china
and now we're doing it again our numbers
are unbelievable and by the way you're
gonna have a very big number
i even say hold off in your vote until
it happens because a lot of you want to
wait till tuesday anyway
it's going to be a great great red wave
but you know what before that happens
and i don't know what it is but the
atlanta fed just predicted a very big
number biggest in the history of our
country
you're going to have gdp coming out it's
going to be announced and it's going to
be announced probably on the first maybe
a day before the first
and if that number is not big you don't
even have to vote for me okay
i think it's going to be maybe the
biggest number in the history of our
country gdp
that's our big number right i'm taking a
chance when i say that you don't even
have to vote for me
okay who here is voting for trump
thank you thank you thank you
all right that's good and are you
waiting till the
tell me are you waiting till tuesday to
do this which is
okay good if you could get out now is
anybody sending in a ballot are you
going in and doing it the old-fashioned
way
that's what i did i just did that but
whatever you do you have to go out and
who here is going to vote for sleepy joe
biden
i had a leader of a country call up he's
a very tough leader tough as hell
they're going to figure it out maybe
although they wouldn't if it was right
if it was good they were not going to
report it
and he said i hope biden doesn't win
because he's always sleeping that was an
interesting sec
this is a killer says i hope he doesn't
win because he's always sleeping you
know i thought he was being funny
i said you happen to be right about that
this election is a choice between
a trump super recovery and a biden
depression
you will have a depression the likes of
which you haven't seen before
maybe 1929 wants to raise your taxes
put regulations back on and remember
this
get rid of your second amendment
remember this
remember this pro-life anybody pro-life
there's so many
so many different things this is the
single
biggest election in my opinion and i
never thought i'd say it
in the history of our country this is
the biggest
the biggest in the history of our
country
it's a choice between a trump boom and a
biden lockdown he'll close it up
he'll close it up it's uh it's really
something and you know we talk about the
american dream
we had the american dream it was all
coming together there was going to be
believe it or not
unity i was getting called from people
you wouldn't believe it
and then we had this thing come in it
came in and it came in very unique
the invisible enemy came in and we went
back to work and we saved two million
people it was gonna be 2.2 million
people
we say maybe more than that but it's a
choice between the american dream and a
socialist
nightmare that's what it is and the
reason it's such
an important is because you've heard me
say it many times
our country will never be a socialist
country
and that's where they want to take it
that's where they want to take it
that's where they want to think i'm
fighting for the dreams of all americans
including millions of truly amazing
hispanic americans who's hispanic
who's hispanic
oh they're shocked they don't believe it
you know the polls with hispanics are
through the roof they're reporting on it
i said i never had a problem i always
liked hispanic
but they're really they're getting to
understand me and the incredible
progress that we made
so the polls with hispanic americans are
the highest
ever in the history of our country for a
republican
but it could be that we're going to top
them and once we top them
you're going to forget about them
because we've really gotten along
the po by the way who saw the debate the
other night anybody
anybody watching
you see the poll 91-9 that's
i don't know 91-9 that's not bad
i got angry at the media i thought it
should have been better than that
and i felt like perry mason because he
he admitted right at the end his last
name
i said does that mean you don't like oil
joe
yeah well uh uh that was perry mason you
have a watch right
columbo how about colombo it's the same
thing right at the end does that mean
how did he blow it he's been they've
been working for five days
and then they had to go to pennsylvania
where fracking's a big deal right
and how about texas you think they like
him in texas no oil
think of this no oil no gun second
amendment
no god religion and he and then i hear
trump has a one point lead in texas i
don't think so
you know i used to hear this four years
ago all the time he cannot win the great
state of ohio he must win
we won by eight points
trump has never done this before he
cannot win texas under no circumstances
he cannot win texas we won i don't know
by a lot whatever
remember utah we had the guy from utah
he was a specialist in utah
he was going to win utah he came in
third even crooked hillary beat that guy
remember he shaped his
nice nice shaved head nice guy you
remember his name yeah i remember his
name
he's one of the others another another
rhino you know we have
we're against a lot
i didn't start
i'm an innocent bystander every time
that starts he
he started it so i always act extremely
innocent they start
all i have to do is mention her name
crooked disgraceful
deplorable irredeemable
you know they said deplorable and
irredeemable she
who would have thought her speech would
have turned out to be she came out she
said
deplorable but she also said
irredeemable and to show you what i know
i said oh she used the word irredeemable
about our people that's terrible
but it was deplorable that caught on
right but whoever her speechwriter is
i don't want him or her that was a
disaster but i never thought it was
going to be that bad you know the next
day i showed up at a rally
everybody said i'm a deplorable i'm a
deplorable
oh boy but she was a lot smarter than
sleepy joe but they've got a little bit
different kind of a thing going right
now they're more desperate you know
they're more desperate
they're totally desperate because they
have a candidate i mean let's not kid
ourselves
they took him off the stage yesterday i
just saw that right
they he called me george he thought i
was george bush
he called me george
that's unbelievable you know
i didn't know if i was happy or if i
wasn't
because he called me i mean you know and
his wife was sitting right next to him
and she's looking like
huh santel
you could see she was under great great
stress
for the last four years by the way
these suckers are moving like hell i
think let's go off those you know
isn't it nice to have a president that
doesn't need a teleprompter
they are moving like crazy
they are moving like crazy and that's
okay with me
thank you thank you
thank you and i love you i do
i love you i love you
you know that's the phrase and they say
it i think even the fake news would
admit it
nobody's ever heard we all liked ronald
reagan but nobody ever said we love you
we love you we love you
and and he wouldn't get crowds like this
if ronald reagan who i consider be
top-notch if he came here he'd have a
couple of hundred people legitimately he
had
he'd go into a ballroom someplace inside
he'd go into a ballroom
and it'd have a two three hundred people
and that's for you know that's what the
standard
we're having 25 30 35 40 45
000 people
[Applause]
and i'd leave some of these crowds we
were packed in florida and all these
places
and i'd leave some of the crowds and i'd
look at that look at that you can't even
see
the end you can't even see if if they
were legitimate they'd show they never
show it on camera
they never show it on camera
they never ever show it
they don't like to show it you know what
they do show
barack hussein obama yesterday they made
the mistake
the camera slipped and they showed his
crowd he had about 20 people there
which was about 10 people more than
sleepy joe had yesterday
you know you saw we were in pennsylvania
right you saw that
and we had three rallies all in
pennsylvania it was
incredible thousands and thousands and
thousands of people
and joe was in his basement and he saw
it and his handlers much more
importantly saw it
they say sleepy joe we have to get you
out of here we got to move you into i
mean it's not looking good because you
know
they put a lid on you know a lid for a
garbage can this is for
that's where it comes from they put a
lid on and he has a lid today again the
guy's got lids every damn day
and then he said he doesn't want to have
big crowds
really because of covet he doesn't
he's such a great citizen he's such a
great guy then why did he cheat so much
with hunter where's hunter by the way is
hunter where's hunter
where is hunter
remember we did the t-shirt where's
hunter it's sold like
[Music]
now we have it's called the laptop
from hell the laptop from help
this is the greatest laptop i've ever
seen this thing is gold
it's called except for the news that
doesn't want to look at it they refuse
to look at it this is the laptop from
hell
it's the worst nobody's ever seen
anything like
it except for anthony weiner that was a
long time
i would rate anthony's maybe even worse
i don't know anthony that was not good
for the last four years i've been
delivering
the hispanic americans a message like
they haven't heard for a long time
i'm fighting for school choice right
right
school choice big deal safe
neighborhoods
hispanic-owned small businesses we have
great great
business people here i know some of them
i've helped some of them
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
you know i have a reputation for not
paying and it's a false reputation
when somebody does a lousy job like a
microphone that's no good or like
teleprompters that fly with the wind
i say don't pay them but we love our
incredible hispanic american members of
law enforcement that we have a lot of
them
we achieved the lowest hispanic in frank
the lowest hispanic american
unemployment
ever recorded not even close and we're
getting back to those numbers again
the last number of months 11.4 million a
record people were hired
joe biden would obliterate every single
thing that we've done he's looking to do
that he's looking to obliterate
our tax cuts he wants to so we gave tax
cuts
the biggest in history he wants to end
the tax cuts
he wants to end the child
tax credits a thousand dollars per child
he wants to end them
wiping out your small businesses with
lockdowns regulations
gutting your police departments and
devastating your families
with the massive tax hikes i said it's
the biggest in history
it's not going to happen you know why
it's not going to happen because he's
not going to win
we can't have him he will attack
religious liberty and his running mate
the most liberal member of congress
she makes bernie sanders look like a
super conservative okay
i don't think she's for the people of
arizona or nevada
and we want to know who are their
judicial nominees who are they
who are you going to put on the court
you know they want to pack the courts
right
how do you like our nominee amy
right
biden wants to ban charter schools fund
extreme
late term abortion you know what's a fun
late term
even even beyond late term you saw the
governor of virginia
the child is born and then they make a
decision
as to execution of the child you saw
that the governor of virginia and biden
biden totally supports him and surrender
your country
to the violent socialist mob take a look
at philadelphia last night
take a look and we offered to go in
would stop that in two minutes
would offer to go in and they said stand
back
stand back to the police the police want
to do their job
they don't want that to happen they're
good i think they endorse me too
everybody all police departments
endorsements
that's why we are going to win
a record share of hispanic americans of
african americans of asian americans
we're going to win a historic share of
women remember last time
he will not get he will not
get women remember
he will not get women well it didn't
work out that way right the end of the
night
i don't know what happened he got a lot
of women we did very well with women you
know why
women are very smart they want security
they want safety
if they're from suburbia the suburban
women they give me a hard time on
suburban women the people the fake news
you know what they want they want
security
and they don't want their neighborhood
destroyed and i ended the regulation
that would destroy their neighborhood
but i'm not just running against joe
biden i'm running against the left-wing
mob and the left-wing media the big tech
giants
and i'm also running against the rhinos
you know what a rhino is
a rhino may be the lowest form of human
life
i actually sort of like the others
better than the rhinos you know why
wow
that plane's about four days old you
know we have all brand new equipment
f-35s everywhere
we're the envy of the world you know
what we are the envy do you know about
that dan
we're the end look at that sucker he's
trying to show off to the president
yeah that's one of ours i've got to be
sure about it got to be careful
and they have nothing but disdain for
you and for your values they lecture you
you on open borders by the way we don't
have
they want to have open borders you know
we're just now
completing the world the wall will be
finished very soon mexico will be paying
for the world
but they lecture you on everything if a
tree doesn't i love that sound i love it
you don't know what i went through to
get those suckers up there
i had to get that money from the
democrats
oh look at that look look look
oh look at that they gave the president
a little display
[Music]
how about that how about that
i wonder if the fake news caught that
did you see that camera because they
never turned the camera
they don't want to show anything that's
good wow that was something huh
so they were trying to get our attention
with the independent over here
and he got my attention even though he
was very high
but that was beautiful nobody in the
world has the equipment that we have
listen to that
i love it
you don't know how hard it is to get
democrats to pay for that stuff
they don't realize how important it is
they support crippling lockdowns while
their jobs
remain totally exempt they keep your
kids
out of school and you know what they
want to teach in school we don't teach
that in school we've ended that
they're families they have private
tutors they want to take away your guns
your second amendment
your second amendment is so under siege
but we're going to keep your second
amendment nothing's going to be
changing i don't see the people of
arizona or nevada
about 19 of the people here from nevada
oh don't worry i just left nevada by the
way i'll be back there very soon
[Music]
and they all have armed guards we got to
tell these people don't have armed
guards i don't want you to have
from now on no more armed guards let's
outlaw armed guards do you like that
how about nancy pelosi she goes into san
francisco
and she wants to get her beautiful hairy
done
and she ends up with a total trump
supporter as the owner of the beauty
parlor
i like that woman i'm gonna go and have
my hair done by that woman she was
she was great with your vote
man is it windy are you as widget
i think it's from the f-35 that we just
saw
with your vote you can send the wealthy
liberal hypocrites a message that
they'll never forget
under biden's cruel and senseless
lockdowns
countless americans will die and you
know this
from suicide drugs deferred
medical care there's so many different
things
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem
itself
and arizona you're opened up but nevada
get your governor to open up your state
please
get them to open up your state nevada
get them to open get them to open it up
if you vote for biden your kids will not
be in school
he wants to shut it down he was saying
the other day just said oh we'll shut it
down
let me tell you it is devastating for
our nation
and we did just the right thing we
closed it down we understood the disease
it affects like as an example me
guess who had it i had it i'm sure none
of you heard that story
in fact this rally usually we set up
their eyes we don't call them rallies
anymore call them friendly protests
because
you're allowed to protest but you're not
allowed to go to church
you're not allowed to have dinner with
your friends you can't do anything
right you can't do anything so we call
everything a protest this way we have no
problem
no we we have states where you can only
protest you can't do anything
else so we cancel rallies then i had the
idea i said wait a minute
let's just call it a protest and
everybody had we had a lot of people we
had a good time
with sleepy joe there'd be no
graduations no weddings no thanksgiving
they're already talking about no
thanksgiving
and in california you have a special
mass you cannot
under any circumstances take it off you
have to eat through the mask and say
right right charlie it's it's a very
complex
mechanism and they don't realize those
germs they go through it like nothing
they look at you with that contraption
and they say that's an easy one i'll go
right through with the food
now how about california though where
you're supposed to eat
with the mess you can't take it out you
see people
and boy you know when you have spaghetti
and meat sauce that mask is not looking
you walk out it looks like you got into
a fight with dana white winston
you fought one of dana white i saw dana
white does anybody know who dana white
is
looks like you got into a fight with one
of his fighters right
now you can't have christmas you don't
have the fourth of july now we got to
get back to normal but you got to open
up the stage
by the way just so you know on november
4th philadelphia state is open
and on november 4th all of a sudden the
kovitkova cove you turn on television
we have great numbers we have some
incredible numbers you know mortality is
way down and way better than europe and
other places
all sorts of things are happening with
the you know therapies the therapeutics
cures
i think maybe a cure i wasn't feeling
great
and i was surrounded by doctors and they
gave me something
and the next day i felt i could take any
i could take this guy in a fight like
no problem no problem
but sleepy joe i don't think sleepy joe
would be a good fighter do you
as data before one gentle little touch
to the face and he's down
he's down he wouldn't get up very
quickly either woody joe biden's only
idea remember he said i'd like to take
him to the back of the barn
okay now have i ever said that to him
to say he practices violence
the president practices violence that's
right remember he said
i would take him to the back of that's
like if you have to fight somebody
that's
your dream fight right sleepy joe
this guy never lives and now he never
leaves
they had something because i'm doing
three four of these a day and you think
that's
easy right the sun is blazing the wind
is going crazy i did one last night
in michigan it was about 30 degrees
and it was raining and the rain was
going you know sideways like
what are these jobs but we had an
incredible crowd of people
because you know they're all great
they're all like us the same
they love our country that's what
they're doing
and i brought so many auto plants to
michigan if i don't win michigan
that would be uh that would be a tough
one and look what we've done for this
one here
both of you both of you for both of your
states
[Music]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
no it's probably a rhino is operating
they're having a bad day today they're
having a bad day but we're having a good
day
thank you it's all right don't worry hey
fellas don't worry about it it's okay
don't worry about it the biden plan will
crush you
will crush your family we will crush the
virus and you will have
an economy the likes of which we've
never had before
better than last year you had your best
year ever
last year this is going to be better and
you see where we're going it's a
superhero
it's a super supervisor
since the china virus arrived we've
airlifted
amounts of material the likes of which
nobody has done
since the second world war it's one of
the greatest ever
nobody has done since the second world
war
we've pioneered ground-breaking
therapies reduced the
and i'm telling you we're down 85
percent
think of that think of that down 85
percent
nobody has any idea what that means and
that's all been done within a short
period of time
and you know i say it uh so i had it
my wife had it our great first lady does
everybody like our first lighting
she made a speech yesterday in
pennsylvania
and they loved her she made a speech
she's a very elegant woman
she gets it almost as hard as i do they
go after
and she's cool you know she's very
cautious he goes oh that's okay no
problem
me i want to go get them i want to
she goes that's no problem it's no
problem
she's got a very extreme confidence
somehow you know she just
that's okay it's all right she says
that's their problem
not my problem how cool is that bro
but she did a great job she got actually
great views she made a speech in
pennsylvania and it was fantastic she's
a great first lady she really uh
loves you she loves our country but she
had it she got better
i had it i got better but baron had it
barrett
baron is my young son who happens to be
very tall
he's tall hi baron how you doing baron's
14.
when you're 6 foot 5 and you're 14
that's pretty tall
i walk out of the helicopter with baron
hi barry you're having a good time
but he's strong and he goes like the
doctor sean he's a great
doctor he goes he's the white house
doctor
sir baron is tested positive sir i'm
sorry to inform you
i say oh that's bad what does that mean
positive for what
he goes for covid you know we have about
30 names giant virus the plague
whatever you want the plague from china
we have to be accurate
baron has tested positive and i said
that's too bad
like two minutes later said how's baron
doing oh it's okay it's all gone
99.9 right you know they have strong
immune systems
much stronger than our immune system
much much stronger i'm working to make
the breakthrough treatment that i
received and what we're going to do is
we'll make it because i had
a thing called regeneron we're going to
make it
available to anybody that needs it free
free and i do suggest
now i don't know if it helped me or is
it just a power you know i made a
statement
i made a statement and they took it very
seriously cnn fake news total fake
news and i got better very quickly and i
said well i should
because i'm a perfect physical specimen
and i'm very young
they went crazy he's he is not young and
he is not a perfect specimen
they went fresh they went crazy they
they have no sense of humor whatsoever
do they
thanks to our relentless efforts 97
of all emergency room visits 97
are for something other than the virus
think of that
because we understand it now we
understand people are getting better
and you know you're immune that's why i
could jump right there she doesn't mean
i'll kiss the men
i'm not into that but i will kiss every
man there and
kiss every woman there if you don't mind
also
they won't catch anything and you know
what i won't catch because they say
and until i came along right they said
if you have it you get better you're
immune for life
but when i said i had it i got better
they said you've only got four months
they've changed the whole medical
standard if it was anybody else it was
good for life right
but with me they said i'm now good for
four months now i think it's a much
longer period but
who the hell knows we'll know soon
enough we're on track to deliver 100
million doses of a
really great safe vaccine we have some
of the greatest companies in the world
they're right at the doorstep
and if i weren't president if you had
sleepy joe as your president
it would have taken you four years to
have a vaccine you would have never had
a vaccine
what we did with the fda they said sir
we'll need approximately two years i
said how about one week
we moved we moved up the schedule and
yet very very safe
we will vanquish the virus and emerge
stronger than ever before our country
will be stronger than ever before
and what i did only because of you and
the double state
with the double treatment we spent a lot
of money we now have a new little thing
we have a big board that shows different
things
and here's some of the governors talking
about the incredible job we did on covet
or the china virus take a look fact is
every time i've
uh called the president he's quickly
gotten on the line when we asked to get
support for that mercy ship
in southern california he was able to
direct that in real time
what the federal government did working
with states
was a phenomenal accomplishment we got 2
000
of these vehicle field medical sites
that are up almost all operational now
in the state
uh because of his support and those are
the facts uh his team
has been on it i know a team when
they're on it
i know a team when they're not on it his
team is on it they've been responsive
late at night early in the morning we
are working very well with fema region
two with the army corps of engineers
building four field hospitals that was a
decision the president himself took and
i'm grateful for it
these were just extraordinary efforts
and
acts of mobilization and
uh the federal government stepped up uh
we needed help and they were there
he said everything that i could have
hoped
for uh and we had a very long
conversation
uh and every single thing he said they
followed through
we've got to have double the number of
ventilators that we requested for that
area of the state and in fact
uh we got them in frankly short order
have we lost anyone because we didn't
have a bed
or we didn't have a ventilator or we
didn't have
health care staff no the president was
extending support for new swabs
so conversation commitment
uh promise made promise kept
now to be fair maybe biden's not telling
us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barracks
that was terrifying what kind of country
we're going to be
four more years of george georgia he uh
going to find ourselves in a position
where if
trump gets elected uh we're gonna be uh
we're gonna be in a different world
56 of americans said that they were
better off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
they think 54 american people are better
off economically today than they were
in our administration well their memory
is not very good quite frankly
a few moments later i'm running as a
proud democrat
for the senate
so vote visit iowa.com
ohio we got in trouble when we're
running against the senator who was a
mormon
the governor okay well their memory is
not very good quite frankly
can't do it can't do it
you know we have a great great country
but we have a country with
tremendous potential a country that can
be greater than ever before
we can't do this to ourselves we can't
and
i personally don't think he's a nice
person but that's okay i don't think
he's a nice guy
if he was a nice guy i probably wouldn't
have put those clips up
but those clips are just a few of many
many many
clips and this happened over the last
couple of days
you can't do it for instance if you were
here with you today it's i want to thank
the people of ohio for being with him
he's done that seven different times and
once you do that it's over
you just walk off the stage you could
never make a good speech after that
nobody's gonna go home and say that was
a great speech except for the fact that
he called us the wrong
state joe biden has surrendered his
party to the rage-filled socialist
marxists and left-wing extremists and
that's what you're going to have
and you can't let it happen
the democrats have spent the entire year
inciting violence hatred and hatred
against our police our police
without our police we have very little
last night the city of philadelphia was
ransacked by violent mobs
and biden supported people these were
all biden supported people
and he wouldn't even call him out this
morning they said please call them out
he doesn't want to get involved
because he doesn't want to lose the
radical left stores were looted police
cars were burned
and dozens of officers great officers
were injured
biden and harris stand up and they stand
with the riders and the vandals
i stand with the heroes of law
enforcement
[Applause]
it took generations to build the america
we know and love
but if the radical left gains power it
will take them only a short period of
time to destroy it
this election day you must stop
the anti-american crazy radicals they
are
crazy that's why i say this is the
most important election in the history
of our country
i never thought i'd say it because we
had a time last
four years ago but they've gone
absolutely insane joe biden is a corrupt
politician
but big tech will not allow that to be
said and the media will not say it
what he has done is horrible
the money from china from ukraine from
russia
the wife of the mayor of moscow gave him
three and a half million the son the son
had no job no nothing
got three and a half million dollars
they put them on the board of
barista 183
thousand dollars a month and i
understand a three million dollar
upfront payment i think they could have
had him for less
china gave him one and a half billion
dollars to manage
even though he's never managed money
before and i asked people on wall street
is that
common they said it's not common even
for us they don't do that
and that was after a meeting that lasted
10 minutes flew in with his father an
air force still
flew back with 1.5 billion to manage
from china
and then the big one and i guess this
one maybe got caught
i give a lot of i give a lot of credit
for last night
tucker carlson did a great job yesterday
[Applause]
because he was willing to call it out by
the way
follow up sean hannity did a phenomenal
job you look at sean hannity and laura
did a phenomenon
they're getting that word out the great
lou dobbs
jesse we have you know we have a lot of
good support
but the problem is we gotta have more
because look at all those people up
there look at them every one of them
you know they turn their camera off if i
even talk about this think of it
they turned their camera off if i
mentioned biden corruption
they turned their camera off and yet
they'll do stories about me
left and right stuff that's so untrue
no it's unbelievable pretty unbelievable
it's been a lot of fun being your
president i got impeached over a
telephone call congratulations on your
victory
president of ukraine but we had good
stick with the republicans the
republicans stood by
in congress 197 to nothing how about
that that's pretty good
last night in that hour-long interview
the biden family business partner
revealed the depth and extent of biden
corruption
and you know if you walk out your vice
president and your son walks out with
hundreds of millions of dollars
and he's got no real capability i would
say that's corrupt
i would say it's good but joe got a
piece right
for the big guy right they said we're
going to keep 10 for the big guy they
call him the big guy i don't think so
joe was personally involved in
establishing corrupt business dealings
with china
at the same time he was letting china
plunder our jobs and destroy our
businesses
our factories our workers another report
showed that the executive a chinese
company
that paid the bidens at least five
million dollars
was under surveillance by the us
government
as a likely chinese spy is it all
you know this is all down documented
they won't repeat it could you imagine
if i did this
no seriously could you imagine i had a
conversation
congratulations on your victory i never
met the president of the ukraine
i called him up one of my great people
thank you very much
said please call him and congratulate
him i said who is he
president of ukraine and i got impeached
think of it
and we went through hell for six months
our country and they
spied on my campaign before i won they
spied and
after i won they spied and let's see
what happens to him let's all see
and by the way obama and biden knew all
about
it obama and biden knew all about him
if biden wins china wins because
china will own the usa he's going to own
it they're going to own it president xi
i know him well
he has not got the same problems that
biden has
he is a very sharp guy very smart guy
very cunning guy he'll own the united
states i've charged them
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs
i gave 28 billion dollars thank you very
much
china to our farmers because they were
targeted
[Applause]
when we win you win arizona wins
nevada wins and america
we're thrilled to be joined tonight by
some really great friends of mine and
they're warriors and they're fighting
hard
your governor doug ducey he got you
opened up
he got you opened up where's that
where's doctor
you look good doug he got you opened up
you're open thank you very much and i
hear we're doing well doug we're doing
good
i'm going to be so angry at you doug if
i don't get there
i'll call doug doug how are we doing
well he won by about 17 points i'd say
that's not so bad right
thank you doug great job great governor
somebody who's done a fantastic job
in the senate and she's respected by
everybody there including
me she could fly those planes very
easily that we just saw overhead
senator martha mcsally martha
great great so you know
martha's opponent wants to get rid of
your second amendment
i don't think so you know if you talk
about nothing else right
he wants to get his whole thing is he
wants to get rid of your second
amendment they want to take your guns
away
you can't let it happen will you please
win you got to win
okay she's tremendous and you could fly
those planes right
she's the only one in this whole group
that can't congressman paul
gosar congressman great job
great job my warrior he's a warrior
thank you great job
we're doing okay right i hear we're
doing good thank you
congressional candidate daniel
rodemar daniel rodemar
he's a really smart guy but don't mess
with him he was a professional wrestler
he's a big
you're a big dude but i hear you're
doing well i hear you're really doing
well that's good
but we're with you 100 you know that
right
and jim marchand jim congratulations i
hear you're doing well too you and
daniel
he's doing good dan i think so right i
hear good two winners
arizona gop chair who i've liked right
from the beginning
kelly ward kelly
[Applause]
now if we lose i won't like her anymore
i'm going to say you're fired kelly i'm
sorry
but i hear we're doing well kelly right
really well
yeah you have no idea when you watch
your stuff in the fake news you watch it
you say oh
man but the real numbers are we're
substantially up
and also we're up in nevada we're
worried about the governor because he's
a political
he headed the political club that's some
club in nevada
they send out millions of uh ballots you
know they found some
in the garbage can with the name trump
on it military ones
the name trump was on it i said what's
that happening but we got to be careful
with the ballots
we do have law enforcement watching in
your state
you know that we have law enforcement
because it's illegal to do bad things
nevada gop chair michael
mcdonald michael
michael's good going good right
that's really good now we have somebody
else who's been a friend of mine for a
long time respected by everybody
former nevada attorney general adam
laxalt
thanks adam
you are something you're doing we're
doing okay right you get the cheating
you're watching the cheaters and all
those people that send in the phony
ballots
the triple no you had virginia they sent
in 500 000
phony applications they had another one
thousands of
ballots were printed they had one
problem they forgot to put the name
president donald trump on the ballot
that causes a little problem
history says you don't win too many of
those no it's very very dishonest what's
happening but hopefully the courts will
protect us they have to protect us
we had a big win actually yesterday in
wisconsin you know that
where the united states supreme court
said i'm sorry we have an election you
have to get it in you have to get it in
some of these people in nevada they want
to have the election
they want to have the count weeks after
november 3rd
so let's all so let's all wait for the
governor to count them up good and how
many is he going to add during that two
weeks right
a man who i've known for a long time
he's an incredible guy he's a tough guy
he's respected like you wouldn't believe
made a lot of money with something that
he truly loves ufc president dana
white
he's incredible this guy
what a job he does if there was ever a
case for loving what you do
he sees these fighters they want to rip
you apart and he goes up and he likes
them a lot right
they're your friends dana's fantastic
and he has done
a fantastic job with some of the highest
ratings on television dana white ufc
i'm glad he likes me and another friend
of mine who was treated very very poorly
by big tech but he's smarter than all of
them
and he figured this out a long time ago
and he's got a very successful book
that just came out charlie kirk
everybody knows
great charlie
thank you charlie under my leadership we
achieved the most secure border in u.s
history
we built almost 400 miles i'll tell you
about the wall
they kept saying write the democrats we
don't need a wall
we need drones drones all they wanted
they talked about drones
so that we can watch thousands of people
pour into our border
we actually we're all set we have drugs
we have such technology within this wall
we got exactly the wall that the border
patrol wanted
i negotiated with them but they didn't
want to talk about it they wanted steel
they wanted concrete inside the steel
they wanted rebar
inside the concrete we got everything
and they wanted wires all over the place
to hook up to technology
and the democrats said a wall is
obsolete i said war will never be
obsolete
and you know the other thing that will
never be obsolete right walls and wheels
right
everything else is absolutely about 15
minutes after it's developed
joe biden has pledged
to have open borders he even said
maybe we'll take down the wall one of
the biggest
projects of the history of our country
his plan would completely obliterate
so many of the things that you want he
would
do things that you would never have that
you would never
accept he will do things that are so far
left
that we're not going to talk about him
today he will do
things that will destroy our country
this would trigger a tsunami of illegal
immigration
they want to have free health care for
all
free education for all everybody gets a
lawyer that's just what we want as a new
lawyer
everybody everybody gets a lawyer
now we can't have it we can't have what
he has he's also pledged
and he pledges this strong but the good
news about him he can pledge in about
five hours later he will have no idea
what the hell he pledged
but washington democrats continue to
attack
are wonderful members of ice and the
border patrol
more than half of whom are hispanic
americans and many of them are here
today
and i'm very proud to receive the
endorsement
from some of the toughest people on
earth in fact i think they could
actually go to dana and some of them
could be nice good fighters for dana
national ice council the union
representing
our incredible ice officers and a man
who's been a friend of mine for a long
time he's the head
council president just got the
endorsement chris
crane where is chris where is
he you're looking good chris
could some of your people uh maybe fight
in the ufc i don't know
what do you think danny could his people
from mice they like to fight
i think they could dana wants to have
them give them a try out
thank you for all and thank you for your
service chris you do a fantastic job and
the border patrol does a fantastic job
[Applause]
[Music]
these guys data they go into a nest and
they start swinging i don't want that
job you don't want it nobody up here
wants it they go hip and they and you
know what we have moved out chris
thousands and thousands of hardened
criminals horrible criminals
ms-13 we moved him the hell out of our
country because of ice
killers as president i will always stand
i will always stand chris
for the heroes of ice and for border
patrol so say everybody tell everybody
hello give a big hello for me
incredible people we invested 2.5
trillion dollars in the u.s military
including nearly one billion dollars to
build the world's most advanced
guided missile you know where it's being
built right here in arizona
[Applause]
we also passed va choice and va
accountability
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
and we then took out the world's number
one terrorist
solomani is dead he's dead
i withdrew
from the last administration's
disastrous iran nuclear deal
i recognized the capital of israel and
opened the american
embassy in jerusalem
and i also recognized israeli
sovereignty
over the golan heights and instead
of having these horrible ridiculous
endless wars in the middle east
we're making peace you see what's going
on everyone's getting together
there's no blood in the sand
and i was nominated for three nobel
peace prizes
for all different things believe it or
not kosovo serbia you know we're doing
trade deals with kosovo serbia
they're killing each other for many many
years for decades and decades they're
killing each other the two countries
they're killing each other
i said so we're doing a deal with them
deal with what are we doing
i'm not doing any deals unless they get
together they got to get together what
do we want to have people kill each
other for
we made a deal in like about 15 minutes
and they were in the oval office hugging
and kissing and saying how much they
love each other
and it's gonna last believe it or not i
really believe that will last
but you know it's just so natural here
we are they want to make trade with us
more than we want it with them they want
to make trade with us everybody wants
the united states especially
now so i said you know what we'll make a
deal but you guys have to stop killing
each other don't be crazy
it's nice get along and they're getting
along and getting along
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
and a vote for the american dream i'll
vote for the american people
and always remember abraham lincoln the
great
abraham lincoln was a republican we have
to bring that up because most people
don't know that
and i can be more presidential than
any president that's ever served with
the exception of perhaps
abraham lincoln when he's wearing the
hat you know
when he's wearing the hat he's very
tough to be
over the next four years we will make
america
into the manufacturing superpower of the
world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all we'll make it right
here in arizona
we will expand opportunity zones reduce
your taxes
obliterate your regulations like we've
done nobody has ever done what we've
done to regulations and provide school
choice
to every parent in america
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
[Applause]
we will defend religious liberty free
speech
the right to life and the right to keep
and bear arms
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
nobody has the equipment that we do we
are the envy of the world militarily
nobody has done and when i
came the first week i was told by one of
the world's most
overrated generals sir we have no
ammunition
now we have so much ammunition we don't
know what the hell to do with it okay
all made in the usa all made in the us
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will answer right you like that
thank you we will let surprise medical
building
require price transparency lower drug
prices look we took drug prices
last year was the first year in 52 years
where prices went down i'm very proud of
that but it was just
a little bit but they didn't go up but
they went down first time
but now i've invoked favorite nations we
pay more than any other nation in the
world by far
the drug companies hate me big pharma
hates me they are spending so much
and what i did is i made it favorite
nations we're the most expensive by far
in the world
we now go down to the least expensive
tide
with the least expensive in the world
it'll have a 50
60 70 80 reduction in drug prices
and i am not liked very much by those
drug companies
so when you see those ads one after
another they make sleepy joe look like
peanuts compared to the drug companies
nobody has more money nobody's more
powerful in terms of lobbying
but i had no choice i had to do it i
have to do what's right i don't care i
mean i have to do it
we will protect your social security and
your medicare which joe biden
you saw that joe biden tried to
obliterate
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states
will be the first nation to land an
astronaut
on mars maybe we'll make that a woman
too maybe we should make that a woman
too what do you think michael
he said make it nancy pelosi that's
who said that that's pretty good after
that oh stand up please look at this guy
[Applause]
that's pretty good i didn't say it i'm
just repeating it you know
they'll say they say he incites trouble
he loves trouble no i don't
thank you very much that was very good
are you a comedian professionally
great we will stop the radical
indoctrination of our students and
restore
patriotic education finally
it's already happening to our schools
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag right
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust you know they tried
they tried to take the word god out of
the pledge of allegiance you saw that
they did it once i said oh they made a
typo and they did it a second time i
said that's not a typo
and then they had the wrath of the
american public
against them and they put it back but
that's where they're coming from
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
arizona
and nevada and nevada i gotta have those
people they're great
they've been great thank you thank you
all right you have to stop i'll start
crying they'll say the president was
crying today
the president broke down into tears as
they screamed we love you
from tombstone to prescott
from phoenix it's like i have a good
memory because you can't see this sucker
it's moving like
lucky i have a memory would that be bad
you are so lucky you people that i took
you on this journey with me
i say that to all my people i say it to
all my people as the press just
absolutely they're disgusting
i say to all my people you're so lucky
charlie you're so lucky i took you over
this channel
i say it to all my people where's hope
is she
does anyone know hope look at hope
they're so lucky look at that group of
people
this jared is making peace in the middle
east that's all he cares about is peace
in the middle of
he's in the middle east
he's a brilliant guy i'll tell you don't
get guys like that but he's done a great
job and you have jared
you have done an incredible job and he's
done it the exact opposite of what
they've been doing for
40 years you know that great job
mesa to human and from phoenix
to right here in bullhead
that sucker is moving so much i see
i'm trying to go up is my head moving up
and down like this
you did a great job of anchoring these
things fellas a great job
you did a great job this is what modern
and all you have to do is put another
two stripes sorted you'll be fine
but we inherit the legacy of american
patriots who poured out their heart
sweat and soul to secure our liberty and
to defend our freedom
this great state was settled by some of
the toughest men and strongest women
ever to walk on earth arizona is where
wyatt earp and doc holiday how about
that
became american legends it's where the
great american west became
the american dream and arizona is the
state where
generations of pioneers and prospectors
miners
ranchers cowboys and cattle hands
marshals and lawmen tame the frontier
brave the blazing sun that i'm braving
today
i'm just as brave as they are i'm
standing up here i'll be like a lobster
and showed the entire world how the west
was won
they helped make america into the
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come
proud citizens like you help build this
country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are taking it back don't ever let
a bad thing happen on tuesday don't let
it happen we can't let it happen
can't let it happen we're so proud of
our country we can't let it happen
you know when that goes when it goes you
look at venezuela this would be a
massive version
of venezuela and it can happen because
the ideology is the same
it can happen don't let it happen we are
returning power to you the american
people
and with your help your devotion and
your drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of arizona
and nevada and nevada we'll never forget
nevada we're going to have a tremendous
win are we going to win in nevada please
we got a lot of people here a lot of
people a lot of people from nevada too
we have made america powerful again our
military
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong
again we have made america
proud again we have made
america safe again and we
will make america great again
thank you very much go out and vote go
out and vote
thank you everybody
[Music]
i said
[Music]
your dough you can stay there and i'm
sure you will find
many ways to have a
good time
it's fun to stay at the ymca
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
but you've got to know
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i said
someone came up to me and
hang up
there's no need
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
smile
you must have seen
[Music]
[Music]
always with me tiny
dancing in my hand
[Music]
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets are gone
turning
[Music]
is
[Music]
looking on she sings the song
the virgin knows
[Music]
and you can't hear me
when i stand softly
[Music]
slowly
count the headlights on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
him
you